actually spent my first job teaching i
know quiet well I had a real fixation on
these kinds of problems
once we've done a really simple setup
there's almost no information on here
okay but as you've tried it it's quite
complex right and not just as it complex
but there's lots of different ways to
solve it and going around seeing the
ways you guys have solved it I've seen
at least three different approaches and
my none of you've taken my expression
partly because mine's somewhat obtuse
it's a bit of a weird way to go about it
I'm going to show you I think the
quickest way which i think is James's I
think I'm looking at falling right now
I'm just gonna explain it to you and
then I'm going to show you mine anyway
cuz I like it and there's a good wrist
or exactly used for in other situations
where Dave's on earth doesn't work
because mine takes a crew first shortcut
you'll see in a minute let me get
another color Corrections okay sure
quickly if it in any stage I've
misrepresent your James but I think the
first thing you do is well let's put
some information on here that you
already know okay so even if it's not to
scale this is gonna be your arm you have
three centimeter side and your long
one's gonna be six okay you've also got
three RP are close you know it's often
an angle and you've got a right angle
here right angle here cuz both
rectangles and most people said okay
let's call that X okay because you've
got to work it out eventually if you
want ten off you're gonna be in some
kind of a new triangle there are other
ways to do it you could use this
triangle in here sort of fuse you do
that and then you might have your sign
rule or inverse tan or whatever still
works but I think this weighs a bit
what's missing well okay now to work out
what the side is because they you just
got opposite one adjacent how do you go
about it and I think what you can use is
congruent triangles okay
the ones we're really interested in are
on this one here and this one that's
faces so you sort of gotta put your hand
on an angle okay
so how can you
that they're congruent well if you've
got this angle in here right this is 90
minus alpha because of in summer
triangle vertically opposite gives you
this and because that's also Nonie
that gives you alpha over there as well
so all your angles are the same and
you've got a side already matched up
okay so it's an a a yes hey yes okay
once you've got them being congruent
then what do you do because this is we
called this X right but we already know
that this is six centimeters across so
that means that's 6 minus X okay but by
congruence that's 6 minus X right so now
that you've got this triangle basically
set up you just have to use Pythagoras
so I think you get let's see here x
squared plus 3 squared equals 6 minus x
squared plus 9 36 12 X Squared's cancel
I think eventually you get X is like 20
right 27:12 yeah and now you can say but
tan alpha is X on three right yeah I
have it signified that's what's wrong
that should be divided by 3 so 9 on 4
that's better
okay so tan upper is X on three opposite
on adjacent 9 on 4/3 use 3/4 which is I
think a couple of other people partners
got it that way now let me show you my
freedom different way of doing it which
basically is the same it's that it's
much the same I think at this point
it'll be the same but I just wanted to
avoid Korra triangles because common
trends are very specific and they don't
use anything to do with trig which you
guys actually know a lot about okay so I
I took this angle here okay without
having proven that they're congruent so
just pedal back
right I called this X as well so this is
6 minus x2 I already know that's 3 I
haven't called this 6 minus X yet
because I haven't proved that their
contract but up here I can say look this
is a right-angled triangle as well okay
what's useful to me is if I take that 90
minus alpha okay I can relate it to X by
saying opposite on hypotenuse
can you see that's the this is the
hypotenuse okay
so opposite by hypotenuse is sign okay
so sine of 90 minus alpha is 3 on 6
minus X that okay that's just regular
writing in Traill well I know what this
is right sine of 90 minus alpha by
definition that's first time right okay
now right at the beginning you already
knew that tan of alpha is X right so I
putted the close to the other side and
you know getting this sine is equal to I
think it's X on 6 minus X your 3s cancel
because they're on the top so why is
that useful because you can bring it
back to the first triangle that you're
in and without knowing that this is
congruent I already know it's that so
this that's the same as this side so you
end up getting saying well sine alpha is
not just this from a top triangle but
it's this from that triangle okay
because it's opposite yeah
which gets you to this and this
denominator being the sandwich and a
proceed in the same way okay
Saved by the Bell I'm